[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The black men of the
community could not
play hockey with the white
hockey teams in the area.
They were just segregated.
- We've got some
season ticket holders
that are complaining
about bringing you here.
- I had to endure everything,
all the name calling,
the n-word, I heard it all.
- He got death threats.
You're playing the
white man's game.
- You know you can
compete with the best.
But you're the wrong color.
- For 12 years we've
been coming to hockey,
and he's only the second
one we've ever seen.
- Was there a
discrimination issue,
or was it simply
the fact that he
was too proud to go
to the minor leagues?
And you can find good
arguments on both sides.
- There was racial slurs
coming from every corner.
- Only way to get back
at them is to win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Race, like so many other
things, serve as a distraction.
And the minute you allow
it to distract you,
you'll never reach
your destination.
- Doesn't matter
what color you are.
If you want to do
something, you go and do it.
And don't let anybody
tell you can't do that.
- Why wouldn't you
play basketball,
or why wouldn't
you play football?
And I'm like, why
can't I play hockey?
What's wrong with it?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I didn't realize this at that
time that I had broke barriers
and opened doors.
- Our job is to keep building.
You've got guys like Wayne
Simmons and Chris Stewart
and PK.
- He had a dream to
be a hockey player,
and he wasn't going
to let anybody
take that away from him.
- They made it so much
easier for us to come up
and to play and to not think
about color as a factor,
just based on our skill
and not on our color.
- Hockey has given me
so many opportunities.
And the only reason why I
even have that opportunity
is because of them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- You owe it to yourself,
if you're playing a sport,
to know your history.
Especially if you're black.
[END PLAYBACK]
NELSON BOYCE: Wow.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
So I can't begin to tell you how
excited I am to be moderating
this panel today.
We've got an esteemed group of
panelists on the stage today.
And I'd like to briefly
introduce each of them to you.
And I'm sure each of them
will have the opportunity
to give you all a little bit
more color into who they are.
But on the very
far end we've got
Kwame Mason, who is the director
and producer of "Soul on Ice".
KWAME DAMON MASON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NELSON BOYCE: We
have living history
right next to him,
Mr. Willie O'Ree, who
was the first black
player in the NHL.
We have Anson Carter,
who is a former NHL
player, including many teams
like the Capitals, Bruins,
Rangers.
ANSON CARTER: Local.
NELSON BOYCE: Yes.
Yep.
And last but not least,
we have Jessica Berman
who's VP of Special Projects
and Corporate Social
Responsibility for the NHL.
[APPLAUSE]
So amongst other
things, certainly we're
going to talk about
"Soul on Ince" today.
But we're also going to talk
about the evolution of the NHL,
particularly as it
relates to black folks.
And I will tell you, in full
transparency and honesty,
I'm not the biggest hockey
fan that sits in front of you.
I'm a fan of sports overall.
And I will tell you
without hesitation
that this documentary,
this film opened up
an entire new world for me
in not only understanding
the sport, but understanding
the evolution of the sport
and understanding the
culture within the sport.
But even more so, the
many things that the NHL
is doing in terms of
diversity and continuing
to grow the sport overall.
So let's go ahead and
start with you, Kwame.
And talk a little bit more
about your background.
But what was the inspiration
for creating this film?
KWAME DAMON MASON: All right.
Well, first of all I just wanted
to thank Google for having us
here.
It's a real honor,
and I'm really
pleased to be here
with these great people
who I've gotten to know over
the last couple of years
to just talk about
hockey and what we're
trying to do to grow the game.
For myself, I was a radio
announcer for 14 years.
And in 2005 I ended up working
in Edmonton, Alberta, Canada.
And over there, it's like--
that's just a bed of hockey.
And I was really fortunate
to meet and hang out
with a lot of the
Edmonton Oilers,
and they would send
me to a lot of games.
And sitting in the
audience there,
just how beautiful that game is.
For those who haven't been
to a live hockey game,
you have to go and see one, man,
because it's just incredible.
And looking at that, and looking
at the speed, the athleticism
and all that, and getting to
know a lot of the guys off ice.
The first thing
that came to my mind
was something that
I used to think
about when I was
a child, which was
how come there's still not a
lot of black athletes playing
hockey?
And in that thinking,
I thought to myself,
there are-- or I was seeing--
a lot of young guys coming up.
I was watching Anson Carter.
I mean, I remember sitting
in my room watching
an Olympic games and Anson
scoring the winning goal.
I remember how long it
took to get the referee
to call the goal.
And I was just sitting
there by myself, and just
so happy for him.
And I would go on my computer
and I would Google black hockey
players.
And I would get
this list of guys,
and I'd be reading
these stories.
And then one day I found
out about the Colored Hockey
League of Nova Scotia.
And I was in my
30s at this time,
and that really bothered
me because here I am,
a black Canadian, and hockey
is our second language,
and nobody taught me about this.
So I started to gather a lot of
information and I put it aside,
and I said to myself,
you know, this
would be a really cool
documentary one day to talk
about black history and hockey.
And so we fast forward to 2011,
and something really tragic
in my life happened
where my mom had cancer.
And I remember sitting on
her bed in the hospital
and talking about what I was
going to do in the future
because as a mother,
she was very concerned.
And I said, you
know, I got this idea
to do this documentary
about hockey players.
And she just told me
the best advice ever,
and she said, just go for it.
So after she passed,
I put my head down,
and I started gathering
information, making some phone
calls, and trying to do the
best I could to kind of put
something like this together.
And so fast forward to 2011,
I sought my first interview.
And from then on it
just kind of snowballed.
And it was a long road.
NELSON BOYCE: Let's talk
about that a little bit more.
I mean, first time filmmaker.
You know, I watched
the documentary,
and you're flying
to a bunch of-- you
must have been in a
number of different cities
to have gotten all this done.
Was there funding behind this?
How did you make this happen?
KWAME DAMON MASON: Well, funding
was me selling my condominium.
NELSON BOYCE: Dedication.
KWAME DAMON MASON: Yeah.
I wouldn't advise that for
any filmmakers out there.
But I'm so passionate
about the sport.
I'm so passionate
about black history.
And it just was a great mesh.
And if no one was
going to invest in me,
I figured I had to invest
in myself because I thought
nobody was telling that story.
So if I just said, well, I
don't have money right now,
might as well just wait,
I don't know how long I
was going to have to wait.
And I had already quit my job.
So I had to do something.
So I had some capital and I had
great family back in Toronto.
And they just said,
do what you got to do.
So I sold my condominium
and used that money
to just kind of help fund
going to different places.
NELSON BOYCE: And again,
being a first time filmmaker,
not necessarily
having a name that's
a household name, getting
the likes of Mr. O'Ree
and some others to participate.
KWAME DAMON MASON: Wasn't easy.
Wasn't easy.
I think at the end of the
day, for me, it was trust.
You know, I remember
talking to Anson
on the phone in the early
stages and telling him
what I wanted to do.
And George Laraque
was a great guy
that I had known in Edmonton.
So he was the first person,
one of the first NHL guys
that I was able to shoot.
And I already had shot
Mr. Herb Carnegie.
And from there I think
guys started to trust--
and I was just a pest, man.
I just pestered.
I just called and I
called and I called.
And I mean, the first
time I met Willie--
ANSON CARTER: I
can attest to that.
KWAME DAMON MASON:
I just pestered---
Anson can tell you, man.
I just kind of, hey,
listen, can I interview you?
Hey, can I interview you?
Where you going to be?
I'll interview you.
And you know, I literally
rolled up on Mr. O'Ree
and I said, I'm going
to come to San Diego
and I'm going to interview you.
And the day I went to San
Diego to interview him,
he wasn't even at home.
His wife was at home and
she didn't answer the door.
And she's calling,
there's some young guy
with camera equipment outside.
And he came home and
we did the interview.
But it's just
perseverance, which
is, to me, the theme
of the film, which is
perseverance through adversity.
The adversity for me was,
as a first time filmmaker,
know nobody was going to
give me money for this.
Nobody was going to just
let me into their homes.
I had to keep persevering.
I had to keep telling
them that this
is something very important.
And I think Anson and those
guys can probably say that.
They saw how serious I was.
So they let me have their time.
NELSON BOYCE: And to stay on
that theme of perseverance
for a moment-- and we're
going to go deep dive with Mr.
O'Ree in just a moment-- but can
you give a little bit of color
around--
there were many narratives
in the documentary.
But talk a little bit more
about Jaden Lindo and kind
of how that was kind of a
bit of an anchor in the--
and he went through
some things, clearly.
KWAME DAMON MASON: Yeah.
Well, you know, I wanted
to show a young man that
was going through his
last year of the OHL,
just his draft year.
And there's a couple other
guys I could have really gone--
Josh Ho-Sang was slated
to go in the first round,
so that was a big name.
That would be a great story.
But I really wanted
to show somebody
that I felt was kind of
like an underdog that
was kind of under
the radar, and just
to see what would
happen with him.
And Jaden comes from a really
well-established family.
And one of the
things I wanted to do
was I wanted to show the black
family unit, mother, father,
and supporting a young kid,
because so many times when
we see film narratives, you
always have the broken home.
I wanted to show
a complete home,
and I wanted to show that
hockey is something that
is a very family-oriented sport,
and you need your family there.
So I thought that their
family was a great unit
and had a great story to tell.
And Jaden was a great kid that
when I first met up with him,
he was a shy kid.
And just throughout the year
that I kind of worked with him,
his confidence grew.
And unfortunately he
had a knee injury,
but it didn't stop him from
getting drafted at the end.
And he was able to hear
his name being called.
And I thought that was
very important to show
these young kids that you don't
have to be the superstar guy.
But as long as you
work hard, somebody
is going to recognize that.
NELSON BOYCE: That's right.
That's right.
Perseverance.
KWAME DAMON MASON:
Perseverance through adversity.
NELSON BOYCE: So let's
stay on that theme,
and we're going to transition a
bit over and speak to a living
legend, Mr. O'Ree,
who in 1958 became
the first black NHL player.
Mr. O'Ree, clearly you
were featured in the film.
Tell us a little bit
about your journey.
You're largely and
widely recognized
as being the Jackie Robinson
of ice hockey, if you will.
Tell us a bit
about your journey.
And then talk a little bit
about that comparison and what
that kind of means to you,
and whether or not you
are in agreement
with that or not.
WILLIE O'REE:
Well, first of all,
I had met Jackie Robinson
on two occasions.
I met him in 1949 and then
I met him again in 1962.
But again, I was the
youngest of 13 children.
And I was born in
Fredericton, New Brunswick.
And there were only
my older brother
and myself that played hockey.
My sisters were into basketball
and some other sports.
But at the age of three, I
started skating in my backyard,
and I started playing organized
hockey at the age of five.
And like all Canadian
boys and girls,
there's ice all over the place.
And I had a rink in my backyard.
I used to skate to school.
And then when I was
14 years of age,
I decided I wanted to become
a professional hockey player.
And thanks to my
older brother, who
was not only my brother and my
friend, but he was my mentor.
And when he found
out that I wanted
to play hockey, and hopefully
play professional, and then
hopefully one day playing in
the National Hockey League,
he gave me all the support
that a brother could give.
So I left my hometown
at 17, went up to Quebec
to play my first year junior
with the Quebec Frontenacs.
Coach Phil Watson
was the instructor
who played with the New York
Rangers back in the 40s.
That was my first year.
My second year I spent in
Kitchener, Ontario, Canada,
Coach Black Jack Stewart
was the second coach.
And back then,
none of the players
wore any helmets,
no face shields.
Goalies didn't wear any masks,
so your face and head was
exposed to pucks and sticks
and everything else that
was flying around on the ice.
And an unfortunate accident.
I'm in front of the net,
a slapshot ricocheted.
The puck come up and struck me
in the right eye, hit me flat,
broke my nose, part of my cheek.
And I remember dropping
down to the ice,
and the next thing I know I'm
being placed in an ambulance
and taken to the hospital.
I'm in my hospital bed.
Dr. Henderson was the surgeon,
come in and stood by my bedside
in my recovery room,
and said Mr. O'Ree,
he says, I'm sorry
to inform you,
he says, the impact of the puck
completely shattered the retina
in your right eye.
And he says you're
going to be blind
and you'll never
play hockey again.
Well, I'm 19 years of age,
and the goals and dreams
that I had set for myself
of playing professional,
and hopefully playing in
the National Hockey League,
were gone.
So I laid in my hospital bed.
And I get out of the hospital
in the next three days.
Within the next 10 days
I'm back on the ice
practicing and playing.
The only difference
I felt about myself,
I just couldn't see
out of my right eye.
Now imagine being a left hand
shot and playing left wing.
So to compensate, I
had to turn my head
all the way around to the
right to pick the puck up
with my left eye.
And I was over skating the
puck and missing the net.
And I said, Willie,
what's wrong?
So I just said, forget
about what you can't see
and concentrate on
what you can see.
So my game started to pick up.
I started scoring some goals.
And now the season's over.
And I either have to
turn pro the next season
or play amateur.
And I was keeping
my fingers crossed
that I would be contacted
by a professional team.
So I returned home
to my hometown.
And Punch Imlach, who was
the coach and general manager
of the Quebec Aces, the
professional team up in Quebec,
contacted me and
said, Willie, he says,
I watched you play the
last couple of years,
he said, I'd like to invite
you to training camp.
So I went to training
camp and I made the team.
But I didn't disclose the
fact that I couldn't see out
of my right eye.
I never took my eye exam.
So I said, if you're good enough
to make the team with one eye,
I said, don't worry about it.
So I made the team.
We won the
championship that year.
That's what gave me the extra
confidence that I needed
to go on and play pro hockey.
NELSON BOYCE: That
is incredible.
So not only you had the kind
of weight of being pulled up
with the Bruins after
they had some injuries,
being the first black
player in the NHL,
you had sight only in one
eye this entire time, which
was an additional load on
top of you at the same time.
WILLIE O'REE: Yes.
I went to the Bruins training
camp on two occasions,
in 1957 and '58.
And they didn't
take any eye exams.
They were more concerned
about your physical condition.
And I always kept
myself in good shape.
I worked out in the summertime
and worked in the gym.
So when I went to
training camp, I
was probably one or two pounds
away from my playing weight.
So when they called me
up on January 18, 1958
to play two games against
the Montreal Canadiens,
when I stepped on
the ice that Saturday
night in Montreal against
the Montreal Canadiens
and became the
first black player
to play in the
National Hockey League,
it was just a thrill for me.
I was no stranger
to the Montreal fans
because I had played against
the Montreal Junior Canadians
in the Forum and played
against the Montreal Royals,
the professional
team in the Forum.
When I skated on the
ice that evening,
I was just Willie O'Ree
with the Bruins Jersey on.
And I could see fans pointing
in my direction and wondering,
oh, he's just a black player up
with the Bruins with number 22.
ANSON CARTER: And
I can tell you,
it's hard enough to play with
two good eyes in the National
Hockey League.
So to be able to do it
with one is impressive.
NELSON BOYCE: No, listen.
I'm trying to put it all
together in my head about how
that worked out.
KWAME DAMON MASON: You almost
have to, like, pick a day
and just walk around like
this and see how hard that is,
and then imagine--
ANSON CARTER: A day?
An hour.
It's not a day.
NELSON BOYCE: Yeah.
With flying projectiles at
60 some odd miles an hour.
When you look back on your
professional career, Mr. O'Ree,
can you recall one particular
moment that was a highlight,
and maybe one
particular moment that
was a low light for
whatever reason?
WILLIE O'REE:
Well, the highlight
was when I first scored my goal
in the National Hockey League.
It was January the first,
New Year's night in Boston
against the Montreal Canadians.
We're warming up.
One of my teammates,
Bronco Horvath,
said Willie, if you ever get
in on Hodge, keep the puck low.
He's weak on low shots.
Keep it away from his club.
Jacques Plante, who was the
number one goalie, was out,
and Charlie Hodge was
the backup goalie.
So we're skating around and he
says, remember now, if you get
in low, low on him.
So it was the
third period, and I
remember I had just
broken away from my check.
And I'm busting
down the left wing.
And Leo Boivin, one
of my defensemen,
just hit me with a perfect pass.
I didn't have to break stride.
So I'm going in
on the defenseman,
and I go get the
defensemen out of position.
Now I'm going in on Hodge,
and I got my head up,
and all of a sudden I can
hear this, low, Willie, low.
So I go in and shoot the puck.
And it either was right along
the ice or just was off the ice
and hit the inside of
the post and went in.
That made it three to
one for the Bruins.
And then about
seven minutes later,
Andre the Pocket Rocket
scored the second goal
and made it three to two.
But the goal that I scored
was the winning goal.
And the Bruin fans gave me a
two-minute standing ovation.
I'll never forget it.
It was quite an evening.
NELSON BOYCE: That's phenomenal.
And perhaps one low
light, if there is one?
WILLIE O'REE: A low light?
Yes, a low light.
It was my first
trip into Chicago.
One of the original teams
in the original six.
I was warming up.
And I won't mention
his name, but one
of the players,
big right-hander,
came around and gave
me a two-hander right
across the ankles
as we're warming up.
And he looks up and he's jawin',
and he made a racial remark,
but that didn't bother me.
So anyway, the warmup's over.
We come out first period.
It's about six minutes
into the first period.
I'm in behind the net
and I got the puck,
and I dump it out to my winger.
And this player come in, and
he caught me on my blind side.
I couldn't see him.
And he stuck about six
inches out on his stick,
and he hit me and split my nose,
knocked my two front teeth out.
And my teeth just
dropped down on the ice.
And now he's just
standing there.
And he made a racial remark,
but that isn't what set me off.
He just stood there and smiled.
Now he was about six three, and
I was five eight, five nine.
So I took my stick and I hit
him right over the head with it.
And I cut him for a
number of stitches.
And then my stick broke.
Now I know we're going to fight.
So I dropped my gloves
and he grabbed me.
Much bigger, and he hit
me a couple of times,
and we go back up
against the screen.
And the first thing
I said, just hold on,
Willie, just hold onto
him so he can't hit.
Meanwhile the both
benches emptied.
All the Chicago
Blackhawks come out
of their bench, all the Bruins
come out of their bench.
was there was 92
minutes in penalties
assessed on the players.
Now I go into the room, and they
stitch me up and plug my nose.
And at least I want
to come back and sit
on the bench with the team.
But coach Emile Schmidt
said Willie, he said,
these fans became so
violent that I'm worried
about you getting bodily harm.
So I had to stay in
the dressing room,
and they had two police officers
outside the dressing room
the entire game.
Now this was six minutes
into the first period.
And I stayed in there,
and the first thing I did
is I just turned the lights out.
And I sat there and
I kind of meditated
for a couple of minutes.
And then I turned
the lights back on
and I said, no, Willie,
I says, if you're
going to leave the
league, it's not
because some joker is
trying to get you out.
You have the skills
and ability to play
in the league at that time.
So basically that was
about the worst one.
The next trip in,
it was not as bad.
But I finally gained
the respect of not
only the players
on the opposition,
but fans in the stands.
NELSON BOYCE: That's right.
KWAME DAMON MASON: But you
did meet him later on in life.
WILLIE O'REE: I met
him 30 years later.
KWAME DAMON MASON:
Did you give him one?
WILLIE O'REE: I met him.
The NHL All-Star
game was in Chicago.
I got an invitation
to the hockey club,
and then they called
me on the phone.
And I said, well, why are you
inviting me 30 years after I
left the league?
Why didn't you invite me
five years or 10 years?
They said, well, we realize
that you broke the color barrier
and we'd like you
to come to Chicago.
So my wife and I
went to Chicago.
And I had reunited
with the players
that I hadn't seen in 30 years.
So we're sitting at a
table seated for ten,
and my wife wanted
a glass of wine.
And there wasn't
any on the table.
So I said, well, I'll go
to the bar and get one.
So I walk out to the bar.
And the bar was
about 30 feet long.
And I walk up and I ask the
bartender, a glass of red wine,
please.
Now who comes beside
me is this gentleman--
I was just about to say his
name-- but this gentleman I
had the altercation with.
And he's tall and he looks
down and he says, hello,
Willie, what's going on?
Not too bad.
And I said, well,
let's get it on,
because I was ready
to go after 30 years.
I had his number and I
said, let's get it on here.
But he went this way
and I went that way,
and we never met again.
But that was about
the only time.
NELSON BOYCE: Well,
that's good to hear
because under the
circumstances, I
can imagine that, over
the course of time,
you could have had a number of
different incidents like that.
And so this is a story,
certainly, of perseverance,
patience, and evolution.
And as a function of that,
let's kind of move on and speak
to Anson for a little bit.
Interestingly enough, there
wasn't another black hockey
player after Mr.
O'Ree until 1974.
That's quite a bit of time.
And certainly you didn't
start playing in 1974,
ANSON CARTER: I was born in '74.
Just goes to show you.
NELSON BOYCE: Want to get your
perspective as a black hockey
player who had a successful
career, in listening
to those types of stories, how
the league, from your eyes,
may have kind of
evolved over time,
and what your
experience in the league
was like in juxtaposition
to that, and maybe
some of the things
you've noticed
as it's evolved over time.
ANSON CARTER: And it's
definitely evolved.
I mean, I know from when
Willie played to when I played,
it's come a long way.
Society in general
has come a long way,
and I would say that sports
mirrors society and vice versa.
But when I was coming up and
playing the National Hockey
League, there wasn't
very many of us playing.
I mean, it's fortunate.
Kwame was talking about
Edmonton, our team in Edmonton.
We had a lot of black players
on our team in Edmonton.
We had Sean Brown, Joaquin
Gage, myself, George Laraque.
And that's kind
of how I was used
to playing hockey in Toronto
because I'm from Toronto.
And everyone plays
hockey as a kid.
It doesn't matter
what color you are
or where your background is.
My parents are
Bajan, from Barbados.
So it was hard
enough to convince
them to let me play hockey.
My parents, you know, ice?
What?
You find ice in your drinks.
That's where you find
ice, not playing hockey.
So that's what I had
to overcome to allow
them to let me play hockey.
But I was another
black player playing
on my team in minor hockey.
So it wasn't a big deal
until I went to high school.
And then I went to
high school and hockey
became a quote,
unquote white sport,
which blew my mind,
because I play basketball,
I played baseball, I
played every other sport
under the sun.
I actually want
to Michigan State
to play hockey and baseball.
And I played everything
under the sun.
But I got to high
school and hockey wasn't
cool again for my black friends.
And it didn't really
register with me
because I guess my
parents say I'm stubborn.
And I don't really care what
people say, people think.
So I just kept it moving.
I didn't really listen to
what my friends were saying.
And I went to Michigan
State, and a reporter
said to me one
time, he was like,
Anson, how does it feel
being a black hockey player?
I sat and looked at him.
I was like, well, I don't
know how it would feel
to be a white hockey player.
So I couldn't tell.
That's who I am.
That's me.
And I've never thought
about it any differently.
But coming to the
league, there really
wasn't, for myself
personally, there
wasn't any situations
where I had
any differences with my fellow
teammates because I was black
and they were white.
Like when my best friend
Janne Niinimaa, Finnish guy,
couldn't look totally more
different than myself.
Finnish, he's from the north.
My parents are Caribbean.
I'm from Toronto.
I'm black.
He's white.
And he loves heavy metal.
I love dance hall reggae
music and hip hop.
And we would always argue
in the drive to the rink
all the time in Edmonton
because he'd have his Metallica
blaring, and I'd come and I'd
try to change the station.
And he'd come into
my truck, I've
got Buju Banton playing, or Jay
Z, or Tupac or someone playing.
But eventually, as we
developed our friendship,
we became to appreciate
each other's differences.
So there's times now, there's
like Metallica playing
in my car, and I'll turn
it up, and my kids are
like, what in the world are
you listening to, Daddy?
That's what Ghost
used to listen to,
so I listen to it now,
too, and I appreciate it.
He sends me text messages
all the time saying, well,
hey, listen, I was
listening to a reggae song.
I was like, we're in Finland?
They play reggae on Sirius?
But that was the cool
thing about playing hockey.
We all had our differences.
We might not have interacted
with each other on that level.
Or we might not
have, if we never
played the game of
hockey, but to be
able to come together and play
at the highest level, I mean,
it's a beautiful thing.
NELSON BOYCE: Let's talk
about that a little bit more
for a second.
So having played in the league,
but somebody who was clearly
talented in other sports.
And we see a lot of times these
days are athletes that could
easily play a number
of different--
what would be your pitch for a
young brother coming up who was
trying to figure out whether
he wanted to go baseball,
football--
just making it up, right--
or hockey.
Like, what would your
pitch to say, join NHL.
ANSON CARTER: I think
Kwame said it best
when he was like, you
have to go to a game.
You need to go
there and experience
it live to see the size,
the speed, the skill,
the athleticism, the
hand-eye coordination
that players need to
play, the reflexes to play
the game at that level.
That's what will draw you in.
I loved playing basketball.
There's no better feeling
than dunking on somebody
when I played basketball.
I loved it.
But scoring a goal had
that same exact emotion,
that same feeling of raw energy.
Hitting a baseball out of the
park, I loved that feeling.
But you score a goal,
same exact thing,
jumping into the glass,
that is pure emotion.
I couldn't find that
in any other sport.
So I would tell people, and
I tell kids in particular,
go to a game and watch a game.
Once you go to a hockey
game, you're hooked.
I mean, now you've
got HDTV, so it's
way better than standard
def so you could find out
where the puck is.
And I tell hockey fans all the
time, don't follow the puck.
Follow the flow of game.
When you follow the
flow of the game,
the puck's gonna find you.
NELSON BOYCE: Absolutely.
And that's a great answer.
And a question for the
three of you, and then we'll
transition to Jessica here.
But having been most recently
in the league, Anson,
can you please explain
to folks what a line is?
And beyond that, kind of
your prediction on when there
may be a first all black line?
ANSON CARTER: So we almost
came close in Edmonton.
When it was myself
and Big George,
we would always
petition our coach.
And Craig MacTavish
was our coach,
and I would say, Mac,
let us play together.
We have Brownie, Sean
Brown on defense.
Let Brownie play
forward this one shift
so we can have the
all brother line.
And speaking of brother
line, I was in Vancouver
a few years ago when I played
my last couple of years
in the league.
And I had myself
in the Sedin twins.
And that was our nickname,
the Brother Line,
because Danny and
Hank Sedin and myself.
But I think you're going
to see it eventually.
I mean, there's going
to be a time when you're
gonna see enough players
playing on a team
where they're going to
come together and form
an all black line.
I think it's only a matter of
time when you see that coming.
Once the numbers start to--
NELSON BOYCE: Three
years, five years?
ANSON CARTER: I would
say five years or so.
It has to start more
at the grassroots level
that we're seeing
that right now.
You're seeing kids coming up
now playing grassroots hockey.
And once those numbers
start to increase,
your base increases because when
you're playing at NHL levels,
it's a pyramid, so you have
the best of the best playing.
But if your base is a lot
wider, than that pyramid up top
gets a little wider as well.
NELSON BOYCE: Right.
That's a great segue, actually,
to talking with Jessica
and finding out
a little bit more
about what the NHL is doing
as it relates to this.
NHL, full transparency, one of
the later professional leagues
to integrate.
But in doing some of
the research for this,
I was pleasantly surprised
at just the amount
of operational work that
has gone into diversity
within the league and continues.
I mean, I read a
little bit about there
being kind of a mandatory
diversity training
preseason for folks that
come into the league.
And certainly the work that
you're doing with hockey
is for everyone.
And having been from growing
up in Flatbush, Brooklyn,
I am sure that
you've grown up in
and are aware of
very diverse places
and have been in
diverse situations.
And clearly your job at
the National Hockey League
continues to perpetuate that.
Can you tell us a little bit
about the why you guys are
doing the things
that you're doing,
and give us a sense of how--
by the way, yes,
Black History Month
is a time frame that we can
shine the light on the things
that you're doing, but
how these things are
happening year round.
JESSICA BERMAN: Sure.
Thank you.
And on behalf of the NHL,
thank you for hosting this.
We talk a lot about
reaching new audiences.
And so this is a great
opportunity for us.
And really appreciate it.
Before I answer your
question, I just have to say,
hearing Anson's story
really hits home for me.
It's the reason
that I do what I do.
It's the reason that I always
wanted to work in sports.
The idea and the platform
that sports brings people
together is what inspired me
to want to work in sports.
From my 16-year-old
birthday, my family
took me to a hockey game.
I had never been
to a hockey game.
My brother was a
football player.
I was a cheerleader for
basketball and football games
and grew up in a very
diverse community.
I went to public school.
And there was a
moment at this game
where the magic of
the game really took
over, and the energy in the
stands but also on the ice.
And the Islanders scored.
And we were sitting right
behind two gentlemen.
It was a kind of the story
you were just saying,
a black and a white person who
seemed to not know each other.
And the Islanders scored
and they embraced,
and they embraced
enthusiastically.
And for those who know me
know I'm quite inquisitive.
And I'm not shy.
So I tapped them on the shoulder
after the moment passed and I
said, do you guys
know each other?
And they said no.
Are you season ticket holders?
Nope.
Please help me
understand this moment.
I watched you embrace and
cheer and hug and high
fiving each other's families.
And they said, the moment of
that goal brought us together.
And at that moment, I turned
to my parents, who were with me
and said, I need
to work in hockey.
And that could have
probably happened
in other venues
and other contexts.
But having grown
up in a place that
was challenged
with racial issues,
I was always very interested
in how to bridge gaps
in our community, in Brooklyn.
And that moment was like, well,
this is the path to do that.
This creates that unification,
that platform where
all of the differences
strip away,
and the pure passion
that exists just
brings them together instantly.
And what I was always wondering
is if those two people saw
each other outside of that
venue, is there carryover?
That was the thing that
always sort of fascinated me,
and still fascinates me when I
work on diversity initiatives,
and the idea that
sports is a place where
we can model that behavior.
And your story
with your teammate
really hits home for me.
And is there carry over
beyond that person?
So do you look at--
and does he look
at-- people who are
different from him
in a different way,
through a different lens, after
having that experience where
your mind was
opened to his world,
and his mind was
opened to your world?
So that's just--
I had to share that
because I'd never
heard that story from you.
NELSON BOYCE: No,
that's important.
It's great foundationally.
JESSICA BERMAN:
And that's really
what draws me to what I do.
But to answer your
question, the NHL has been--
and probably a lot
of people don't
know it-- has been working on
diversity initiatives for more
than 20 years.
We hired Willie in 1998 as
our diversity ambassador.
He has been traveling
from city to city,
market to market, inspiring
the next generation of people,
but also hockey players, to give
our sport a try, whether you're
a fan or a player.
And when we think
about why we do that,
and we challenge
ourselves as to the why,
I think there's
really three reasons.
The first is that--
and the commissioner
always says this--
it's the right thing to do.
We believe in equality.
And we believe that
everybody should have access
to our sport.
And so we always do it because
it's the right thing to do.
And the values of our sport
really perpetuate that
and make that authentic.
You see it in the people
who have played our sport,
and you hear Anson
and you hear Willie.
And really, if you
know hockey players,
whether they're playing
at the highest level
or even in a grassroots
program, hockey players
are unique in that they
have these values that
are all about teamwork and
humility and resilience
and hard work and
sacrifice and dedication.
And it really creates
an environment
where we say with our partners,
if you can play, you can play.
If you can contribute
as a member of our team,
we want you on our team.
And we were actually
talking earlier,
and both Willie
and Anson have both
said although they experienced
racial slurs from fans
and definitely from
opposing players,
among their teammates they
didn't experience that.
And that's because
our sport is really
all about what you
bring to the table, so
the culture of our sport.
The second thing
is that we know--
particularly today, more
than ever before and even
for the last five or 10 years--
there's a demographic shift
happening in North America.
And we want to be relevant.
We want to bring new
audiences into our game.
And so from a Hockey is
for Everyone perspective,
this is, in addition to being
Black History Month, also
Hockey is for
Everyone month, which
is a month where we shine a
light on all of the diversity
inclusion, activities,
initiatives, partnerships,
community engagement that all
of our teams and the league do.
Of course, they
do that year round
through grassroots programming
and Boys and Girls Club
support, and all kinds
of other outreach
into diverse communities.
But February is a time
where we celebrate that.
So again, the second
reason is really just
to introduce our game
to new audiences.
And then the third
is kind of going back
to what everyone was
just talking about,
which is we need to increase
the diversity and the pipeline
into our game.
And so we have 26 Hockey
is for Everyone programs
across North America that
bring tens of thousands of kids
into our game.
We're working on strategies
to help them to transition
into competitive
hockey because playing
the game at a recreational
level is really important,
and we want people to be able
to do it on a casual basis.
But if we want to change
the demographic of who's
playing on the NHL on our stage,
and we all know the saying,
you have to see it
to want to be it,
we need to find ways to
help people to transition
to elite hockey
who look different
from our traditional
population of players.
So I would say those are kind
of the three reasons of the why.
NELSON BOYCE: That's great
reasons, great reasons.
And it really shines a light
on the uniqueness of the sport
and what you all are doing.
And these stories really
give context around all of it
and make it real.
And for me personally, Kwame,
the work that you've done
has really opened up my
world to the sport in a way
that I could have
never imagined,
and has gotten me interested.
I mean, I've been
to one hockey game.
I will tell you the truth.
I've been to one professional
hockey game and it's everything
you said it was.
I mean, very large individuals
who have grace and talent.
And there's a lot of beauty
in the sport when you really
get the opportunity
to view it live.
And now to really
kind of understand
the framework and the
tapestry that is behind it
all really makes it so
much more meaningful.
So I thank you, Kwame, for
bringing that to light.
And please, in our
last minute or so
before we open it up the
questions on the floor,
very interested in understanding
what might be next from you
in this realm.
KWAME DAMON MASON:
You know, I really--
it's weird.
Not to say I don't
know what's next.
But I know my passion lies
in hockey and seeing it grow.
I've been very fortunate.
You've got to understand,
when I left my job in radio,
I didn't know what
I was going to do.
I had no source of income.
I just felt like I needed
to be with these people.
I need to be with this
group of people from the NHL
to help grow the game.
And I kind of--
I figured, I was like, OK, well,
how do you put in a resume?
Why don't you make a film?
Why don't you show them that
you want to be a part of this
and you want to help it grow?
And I've just been fortunate
to work with Jessica.
Last year they had me on
the road showing the film
and talking about it.
And what I want to
do next is I want
to help grow the game by telling
stories and doing whatever
I can to get people in the
stands because like we say,
get them into the arena.
I always sit back
and think, what
if Shaquille O'Neal's
parents said, play hockey?
What if Kobe Bryant's
What if LeBron James'
parents said, play hockey?
And those kids are
out there right now.
And for the black community,
I feel we sometimes
put ourselves in a box.
We say, this is what we do
and this is what we don't do.
When I grew up, hockey
was the white boy sport.
And I was one of those kids
who put myself in a box.
And because my friends
were predominantly black
and they listened to hip hop,
I just did what they did.
But I loved this
game of hockey, but I
felt like, oh well,
I guess that's what
the white boys play.
Then the white friends I had
said, well, blacks don't play.
It's too cold.
Or your ankles are
too short or small.
All these idiotic stereotypes.
And I was just like, OK, and
you have to argue with them.
But I just had no context.
I didn't have that ammunition to
say, no, there's Willie O'Ree.
There's Herb Carnegie.
There was the
Colored Hockey League
of Nova Scotia that was
around in the 1800s.
The first professional sports
organization for blacks
was hockey.
It wasn't basketball, it
wasn't football, it was hockey.
Why are we not celebrating that?
And so putting that
film together is--
because of people like you
that didn't think twice
of the game--
but if I showed it to you,
put some nice little hip hop
in there--
NELSON BOYCE: That did not
go unnoticed, by the way.
KWAME DAMON MASON: I thought
that it would make someone
go, oh, wait a second.
NELSON BOYCE: Yeah,
you caught me.
You caught me.
Well, listen, folks, we've got
about eight or so minutes left.
I want to make sure
that we open this
up to Googlers who are
in the audience who
would like to ask some
questions to the esteemed panel.
We've got mics on both sides.
So if folks have questions,
please let's get into it.
We'll start on this side and
we'll just go back and forth.
AUDIENCE: Everyone,
my name is Chris.
Thanks so much for coming out
and speaking to us all today.
It's been really
awesome to hear.
So one of my questions is
around kind of like the grass
roots, and Anson, like
you were talking about,
kind of like the triangle
and expanding that base.
It's great to hear about
the grassroots efforts.
But playing hockey
myself, a massive part
of trying to go pro is kind of
facing that point when you're
maybe 15, 16, 17 years old,
you're going to leave home,
you're going to go to
a city, play for a team
where you don't
really know anyone,
you maybe don't have
a support system,
you've got to go
play juniors to try
to get to that next
level, or private school,
for that matter.
So my thought is what is
being done at those areas
to kind of offer that
support system for, maybe,
the one kid of color who
is now out of his comfort
zone for the first time and
maybe facing some adversity
when it comes to that?
Are there thoughts of
support in the junior ranks
to try to progress people?
ANSON CARTER: You want to handle
that or should I take that?
JESSICA BERMAN: You can start.
I'll piggy back on you.
ANSON CARTER: So I'm not
sure about the junior ranks.
I just know with myself, what
I do on a day to day basis.
A lot of times people
reach out to me
when they hear
there's a black hockey
player playing somewhere.
And they say, hey, Anson, do
you mind talking to him or her,
and give them words of wisdom?
Kind of let them know exactly
what you went through,
because a lot of times
what I went through
was probably similar to
what they are going through
or they're going
to probably deal
with at some point
in their career.
So I'm not afraid to reach
out to different players.
And it doesn't really matter.
Like Kwame, for example, passed
me Joshua Ho-Sang's number when
he played for the
New York Islanders,
and he's been in the minors
back and forth right now.
And Josh was professional,
not a junior kid,
but he went through
some tough things
during training camp
there with the Islanders.
And he slept in.
He was getting this bad rap.
I think part of it was
because he was a black player,
you're looked at a
little bit differently.
So I picked up the phone
and I made a phone call.
Ii was like, hey, Josh,
we never met before,
but you're messing up.
And I didn't use
that exact language,
but because we're here and--
NELSON BOYCE: We
appreciate that too.
ANSON CARTER: You're messing
up, and I'll tell you why.
I didn't go through
what I went through,
or Willie didn't go through what
he went through for you to come
next and set us all back.
You know what I mean?
So we're not to the point
now where you could screw up
and everyone's going
to think it's OK.
You're still a
black hockey player
and we're still the
minority in the sport,
and there isn't that
many of us playing.
So you've got to to make sure
you do things properly to set
the next guy up the right way.
And I thought it went through
one ear and went out the other.
I didn't hear from the
kid at all for a year.
And then I'm with
Kwame and Willie
at a Hockey in Harlem
event last year.
And this lady walks up to
me and she starts crying.
And brunette, she was
white, just to let you know,
just put it in context for you.
And she's like crying
and she's bawling.
I was like, what's up?
And she's like, I
want to thank you.
I said thank me for what?
She goes, because you
change someone's life.
I go, changed someone's life?
And I'm there with the Deputy
Commissioner Bill Daly,
and Bill Daly was like,
is this lady like--
this lady.
And I was like,
have we met before?
And she's like we
haven't met before.
I was like, so put
this together for me.
And she's like,
I'm Josh's mother.
And I was like, oh, OK.
And she's like, he
didn't call me back.
I know that.
But what you said to him
really made a huge impact.
And you didn't have
to reach out to him,
but we appreciate you
reaching out and passing
on what you had to say to him.
And now he gets it.
So I think it's a responsibility
for people like myself
and people that are still
involved in the game
that we see Willie doing on a
day to day basis with Hockey
is for Everyone.
He travels around, he reaches
out and touches these kids.
And I think my responsibility
as a former pro,
now on national
TV with NBC or MSG
to reach out to these people
and these kids as well
and let them know
what I see to make
their life a little bit easier.
NELSON BOYCE: And
Jessica, do you have any--
KWAME DAMON MASON:
So just to piggyback
on what he said, one of the
things, like with Jaden,
when he was in
that draft year, I
would take him when I was doing
interviews and stuff like that,
I would take him to meet
these guys because I always
thought that that's what they
need, that support system.
Mike Marsden, who was
the second black athlete
to play in the
NHL, got in there.
And he was 18 years
old and he was
told to be that
black superstar that
was going to come out there,
play in Washington, DC,
because Washington, DC at that
time was predominantly black.
But it didn't go the
way we all wanted it.
And he just kept going down
and going down, gaining weight.
And the one thing he
used to tell me was there
was no support system for me.
So if he had other
black athletes that he
could talk to and lean on.
He only had one
other black player
that played with
him, Bill Riley,
but it was just the two of them.
But if he had that
support system,
things would have
changed for him.
So I think that's
one of the things
that Anson and Kevin
Weeks do, and I
hope that the league will
encourage more of them
to do, which is to reach
out to these young guys
and just say hello,
how are you doing?
How's your game going?
What are you going through?
What do you need?
Let's talk.
Because that's
the way it's going
to grow because sometimes
these young black players
in these small areas,
they feel alone.
And lastly, when the film
debuted on the NHL Network,
I got messages, text messages,
tweets from parents saying
that they sat down with
the kids to watch the film,
and their kid wanted
to get back out there
and play because they
thought they were alone.
They thought they were going
through this on their own.
But when they saw
the film and they
saw what Anson and
William and all these guys
went through, they said,
OK, they persevered,
I can persevere through
adversity as well.
NELSON BOYCE: And then
quickly, Jessica, from an NHL
institutional perspective?
We'll take a couple
more questions.
I think we've got a
little bit more time.
JESSICA BERMAN: I'll be brief.
I think there's extra challenges
for minority groups for sure.
But the challenges that
you are identifying
are challenges for everyone.
I mean, it's hard for everybody
to leave home, definitely
more so when you're from
a minority population
and you feel that
extra pressure.
I'll just say from an NHL
institutional perspective,
we've been meeting for
the last three years
with all the governing
bodies to talk about ways
to open up pathways to the NHL.
So hopefully they'll
be more to come.
We actually announced
in September
our Declaration of
Principles as a product
of those conversations, which
is a stake in the ground value
statement that 17 leading hockey
organizations signed on to.
It's kind of like our mission
statement, which is that hockey
is more than a game.
And the benefit
hockey gives you is
to build character, life skills,
and all about breaking down
barriers.
So those discussions
kind of range
from grassroots all
the way up through
juniors all the way up to
minors, NHL, international.
So hopefully there'll
be more to come on ways
that we can increase all
those pathways to the NHL.
NELSON BOYCE: Fantastic.
I want to get everybody in.
I think we started
just a little bit late,
so maybe they'll
grant us a couple
more minutes to get through.
But we'll go over here, and
then we'll come back over here,
and then we'll wrap up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you all so much
for coming again.
In addition to growing
our player base
in terms of diversity,
I think we also,
as hockey fans, want to grow our
fan base in terms of diversity.
And so I'd be interested in
hearing the panel's opinion
on what things we should
be doing as hockey fans
and as a hockey community
to make ourselves a more
open environment for them.
KWAME DAMON MASON: I
think if you know somebody
in the minority community
that's never been,
encourage them to go to a game.
I think that's one of
the best things to do
is to say, hey, come to a game
with me and just give it a try.
They might be like,
oh, it's too cold,
or I don't have-- just be
like, listen, put on a jacket.
Let's go.
And just get them into an
arena and just expose them
to the game.
It doesn't even have to
be a professional game.
It could be a minor league
game because games are games,
and they're just fun to watch.
JESSICA BERMAN: I'll say,
from a policy perspective,
we talk a lot at
the league level
about creating an
inclusive environment.
So I think part of that is us
making sure we have proper fan
code of conduct and
that everybody's
on board as to what is and
isn't appropriate behavior.
But I always say it's
also the fans' job
to create a peer to
peer accountability.
So when I'm in the stands,
even with my family,
and I hear
inappropriate language,
I'll say something
to them, like we
don't want that in our arena.
And you can even see
NHL teams during Hockey
is for Everyone month--
actually yesterday,
the Pittsburgh Penguins
responded to some negative
on social and said, we
don't want that in our game.
And so the louder and more
engaged the positive message
is, the more those people
who are negative and creating
a non-inclusive environment
will quiet down and go away.
And that'll open up
the pathways for more
nontraditional audience
to enjoy our game.
AUDIENCE: So I think it's really
outrageous that Willie is not
in the Hockey Hall of Fame.
What can we do to change that?
ANSON CARTER: Hear, hear.
You're of late to the fight
right now because we've
been [INAUDIBLE] already.
We're kind of working
behind the scenes.
I know several
different guys that
are on the panel that
decides who gets in.
I put the bug in Luc
Robitaille's ear,
Bob McKenzie, David Poile.
I'm all over these guys
nonstop because Willie
is a living legend.
And I know not only what
he's done for my career
to allow me to play in the
National Hockey League,
but also other players.
You see these other superstars
from around the world.
Alex Ovechkin will
embrace Willie O'Ree.
And we talk about
hockey is for everyone.
It's not just minority players.
It's European players, Finnish
players, Swedish players,
Russian players.
There was a time when European
players weren't accepted
in the National Hockey League.
You heard terms like
Chicken Swede, or Russians,
you can't count
on them, or Finns
have no clue what they're
doing out there on the ice.
But part of what Willie does
in breaking down barriers
is letting people know that
we can all play this game.
So absolutely he
can be a builder.
Since 1998, Hockey for Everyone,
over 120,000 kids Willie's
been engaged with and
had conversations with,
encouraging them to play hockey
and the life lessons that come
around with playing hockey.
If that's not a builder,
I don't know what is.
AUDIENCE: I'm sold.
NELSON BOYCE: We'll
take one more question
and then we'll wrap up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you all so much
for coming to speak here.
So this Wednesday
I went to a talk
on the future of
skating in New York.
And someone there
asked a question
about why, in New York
City, the home of three NHL
franchises and the NHL
itself, that the state
of skating and playing hockey
in general is so dismal.
You know, part of why it's
so hard to get into hockey
is that it's
hideously expensive,
and it's hard to get ice time.
And people in New York
who want to play hockey,
if they get serious
about it, they leave.
I was just wondering what you
all have to say about that.
KWAME DAMON MASON: New
York is a basketball state.
I'm not sure what the different
communities are doing,
but I think you have to
look at it in stages.
And I think you have to
go into these communities,
get them interested in something
as basic as street hockey
and ball hockey.
And once you start to attract
kids in the communities
and to see how much
fun that is, it
will transition to
wanting to skate.
And then parents and
families in these communities
are going to try to petition
to get these arenas going.
So I think that's
one way of doing it.
And hopefully it will grow.
ANSON CARTER: You're seeing
a lot of organizations
now, too, building arenas
in prospective cities.
That's important.
That will come with lowering
the costs of playing hockey.
Being from Toronto,
there's a rink every block,
like Starbucks here, basically.
Hockey's not that expensive.
But I hear you're saying
about the limited ice time
here in New York City.
I think everything in New
York in general is expensive,
period.
But having additional rinks,
and a lot of these organizations
are doing that right now.
And you're asking about trying
to get nontraditional fans
to get engaged.
Kwame is talking about maybe
have them come to games,
but also just get
them to try skating.
And just try skating, and
seeing how difficult it
is to get up and down the ice.
And I've got two
daughters nine and 11.
And they can skate now, but
the first time they figured out
how to skate and not
actually fall on their butts,
they're like wow,
this is amazing.
And then I brought
them to a hockey game,
and that took it a
whole different level,
because they're like,
well, OK, skating is tough,
but now these guys
are doing this
on the ice while someone
trying to take their head off
at the same time?
This is out of control.
So I think the combination
of all those things.
You're seeing Adidas now.
They're getting involved.
Kwame was talking
about street hockey.
I think that's
probably the lowest
level that we start
looking at trying to get
the stick in kids' hands.
Stick and a ball.
And once you have that
feeling of playing the game,
then you want to take
it to the next level
because I didn't start playing
hockey as an ice skater.
I started as a
ball hockey player.
I played street
hockey in Toronto.
I was a street hockey wizard.
All my friends were like,
oh, you can't skate.
And I had no comeback then.
I was like, you're right.
It's true, you're right.
But then I figured
out how to skate,
and then I could
start chirping back.
So I learned from a young
age how important skating is.
So I think skating and
just playing ball hockey
are probably one of the
keys to that entry level way
into figuring out if you want to
play the game of hockey or not.
JESSICA BERMAN: I'll
just share two things.
First, you'd be surprised at
how many NHL players didn't
start playing ice hockey.
They played street
hockey, roller hockey.
It's actually quite staggering
when you look at it.
I think in addition
to providing access
to alternative
forms of the game,
there needs to be a
culture shift in terms
of allowing those players who
are not playing ice hockey
and not playing elite
hockey to define themselves
as hockey players.
So if you play street
hockey and someone says,
do you play hockey, I want those
people say, yeah, I play hockey
because hockey is hockey.
And so I think we're trying
to do a lot more in terms
of inclusive
messaging on everyone
who plays hockey is part
of the hockey family so
that those people who are
asked, do you play hockey,
are you a hockey fan, and
they play in their garage
or in their driveway, can say
yeah, I'm a hockey player.
I think the second thing,
in terms of access to ice,
is that the NHL has invested
a lot of resources in intro
to the game, learn to play
programs for ages five to nine
with the idea that there's a
little bit of a chicken and egg
scenario where if you do it--
we were just talking about it up
there, about building rinks.
Well, who's going to play in
them, because our program's
oversubscribed,
supply and demand,
from an economic
perspective, and you're
talking about public
private partnerships.
What are they
going to invest in?
They want to benefit
their communities,
so we need to show the demand.
And in order to
show the demand, we
need to expand the
funnel at the bottom.
And so we're really doubling
down on that five to nine
age range so that we can show
that demand in the community
at a young age.
And that, hopefully,
will spur more investment
in facilities, which will
help break down barriers
from an infrastructure
perspective.
NELSON BOYCE: Well,
listen, folks.
I hope that all of you
are as enlightened as I
am after today's discussion.
And certainly after having seen
the documentary, if you haven't
seen it, make sure that you do.
It's been great to have
you all take the time
so that we could share in
your experiences, which
have been very meaningful
and heartfelt to me.
And certainly from
an NHL standpoint,
really giving us a
window and transparency
into all the great things
that you guys are doing that
continue to grow and
diversify the sport.
JESSICA BERMAN: Are
you a hockey fan now?
NELSON BOYCE: I am
a hockey fan now.
I promise I'm gonna
be going to see games.
Let's thank all
of our panelists.
Thank you all very much.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.